each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
he is the founder and manager of the
rise group in Microsoft Research Redmond
so Rhys stands for research in software
engineering many of the tools and
technologies that you're going to see in
the demo fest later this morning will be
coming from his group and I hope you're
going to enjoy those four firm has many
accomplishments to his name you can read
about them in here but I think it's much
more important that you hear now about
what he thinks of the future of software
engineering hello good morning thank you
for the wonderful opportunity to tell a
little bit about the work that my team
is doing in Redmond so I think the
picture should show you in some times
where we are heading we are heading in
the next generation so and sometimes we
will retire at something at some point
and this generation will take over so
I'm happy to reflect on the future of
software engineering but whenever you
think about the future never forget the
past and so I want to tell you actually
where I come from a tiny bit and so as
you all know software engineering
started in 1968 or that was when the
term was being defined at some school in
ma in Bavaria and it turns out that the
person who defined software engineering
who used it the first time
is actually my advisors my PhD advisors
advisor so in some sense my grandfather
so software engineering runs somehow in
my blood I didn't hear anything about
software engineering until I started
studying computer science there was 83
and then we got a textbook from I in
summer will which is now in the ninth
edition but in one of the early editions
he defined software engineering as
followers produce high quality software
with a finite amount of resources to a
predicted schedule and I think now we
have a more elaborate definition but
this one is still pretty good and what's
really interesting about it is if you
step back and replace software by car
for example or automotive then you get a
different definition automotive or
engineering produce high quality cars
with finite amount of resources to
predicted schedule and that's actually
interesting we are as software engineers
not so much different than other
engineers except that under other
engineering disciplines exists for a
long time and so what I think we could
do is actually learn a little bit from
other engineering disciplines and so
that's one of the thrusts that I wanted
to convey today so I want to talk a
little bit about analytics what goes on
in other engineering disciplines and
whether we can take it over for software
engineering I will talk a little bit
about the hardware industry which had
actually some success and using formal
methods and what does it actually mean
for this software industry and
ultimately we have in some sense and
such exciting times where our technology
changes so quickly that I think as
software engineers we should actually
see where the trend and the technology
is going and so how will future
platforms and future developers look
like and where do they come from do they
come from
only industrialized countries or
actually developing countries so let's
see a little bit where we are going so
these are the three thrusts that I want
to talk about today let's start with
analytics so as you know and hard I am
still a researcher that's where am i
passionate but I'm also a man
as a manager you have to read lots of
managerial books and so one of the
interesting ones that I came across last
year was analytics at work and so this
is written by a professor for economics
and one of the distinguished books from
the last year and what he figures out is
actually all the industry is currently
transforming because we have such huge
amount of data and we use those data in
order to make smarter decisions and he
mentions then let's say financial
services we know that in some sense all
the predictive modeling for the stock
behavior is in some sense ingrained in
the financial service industry in the
insurance industry we have death table
substitutions think about your your
rates for for a life insurance and he
mentioned several industries the funny
thing is he doesn't mention IT and he
does mention software engineering and
then you start wondering why doesn't he
mention IT and software engineer
actually we are good at processing data
but currently we don't use it at all so
let's see how he actually defines
analytics and I found this table in some
sense quite neat so he thinks about
what's the data that we have the data
from the past that we can use for
information for reporting the data in
presence that we can use for alerting
and we can also in some sense interpret
the data and use it for insight for
recommendation and prediction and so
let's just take take two examples
alerting so when in some senses the
stock markets go down because there's
one stock that falls rapidly then by now
in some sense they close a stock market
because of the disastrous effects that
it can have what does it actually mean
for software engineering right do we
have actually an alerting mechanism that
it tells us that something bad will
happen if we continue on this path and
we know that right for if we actually
check in branches or work concurrently
on branches it would be great that I'm
being informed that there's something
else working on the same file and if we
want a later much it
lead to a merge conflict if you want to
ship software I think it's super
important that for example we ship
software so that it hits the market at
the right time for Christmas for example
Kinect but can we actually say six month
in advance whether we will be ready in
time with our in some sense engineering
and what are the mitigating thinks that
we should do so I think we are happier
in some sense this is a huge opportunity
to have an impact on software
engineering if we use analytics so let
me take that make that more concrete
yesterday you had a lot about concurrent
objects and concurrent programming
actually there is one concurrency going
on on a much larger scale is if we want
to develop something like Windows then
obviously we have to split the work and
have to do the work concurrently we
can't do it sequentially and so in order
to do that the system that you use is
actually a version control system and
what you do is in order to isolate the
individual groups from changes that
happen elsewhere you use branches and
then in some sense they have to be
merged later so in some sense what we do
in some sense in the big scale to
organize people and their work is very
similar how we organize the software
themselves and of course there are
benefits and costs to everything so the
benefits is that you can actually work
relatively easily if you're isolated
from the churn that happens elsewhere
but there's a huge cost to it namely you
have to integrate your changes back in
the tree and while you're working
locally somebody else who might actually
depend on your changes doesn't see them
so we use software version control
system since 20 years I think every big
company and then you go to Google hi
friends at Google and I ask them so what
version control system do you use and
how many branches you say and then you
hear Google says on a week
we think that branches are completely
broken we should use them at all and
then you talk to the engineers and the
engineer say we really suffer under
conflict
you go to Microsoft that's what I know
best and Microsoft says we use branches
in order to isolate the people but then
there are other people within Microsoft
says oh and by the way we really have a
hard time to integrate all these
branches back together so we have two
big companies that actually say
something completely different
despite that we are a science in and so
I think it's really time that we analyze
it more systematically what happens with
our version control system and how
should we actually set up these systems
so that they work optimally and of
course we have scientists we will use
some some data and so this is a for
example how worse can it be so this is
just one file within Microsoft I don't
tell you which one and there are little
colors here and little edges and in some
sense it doesn't matter too much it's in
some sense the number of colors that
count and so the dark blue ones are
actually edits so there are probably 60
edits on this code the the turquoise
bubbles are branches so these 60 edits
have to be propagated to 30 different
branches and by the way the black
bubbles are in some sense always undo
operations we saw because something
didn't fail and in order to do this
whole process we needed 200 integrations
that's all the yellow bubbles so there
is a huge process involved in running
big organizations with version control
systems so we want to optimize it and we
want to use analytics to do so so we
won't build alert alerting systems
recommendation systems and and actually
even refactoring systems so how do we go
after it so this is the area of
empirical software engineering and they
use in some sense two different means
qualitative and quantitative qualitative
is will do service we ask the people
what's their perception what goes on and
then we use quantitative data to see
whether there is actually a match and
how we can actually move forward so
let's do that
so we asked the people in in Windows who
do lots of integration what are their
main pain points and since there's
almost no literature but there's
actually one nice paper from 19 2008 in
what's called streamlines branching
patterns for parallel software
development and they mentioned 212 anti
patterns so anti patterns are things
that should you should not do and so we
asked them how frequently does this anti
pattern occur in your experience and how
high is the impact and they can probably
mention four that came out so BIGBANG
merge is when all the the binaries are
merged together at a single point in
time and that's obviously a bad idea
because in sometimes you get too much on
development freezes before we actually
ship a product we really want to make
sure that we have a stable version and
so it has a consequence
such as all the work stops and people
are really annoyed and these are - in
some sense managerial decisions that we
can't fix but there are two other ones
integration wall and branch manya which
in some sense we can address and so how
did we go after them so integration wall
means that there is a misalignment of in
some sense the branch structure and the
work that people are doing their goals
what they want to achieve built a
particular feature and so here is how we
go after it using quantitative means so
we said okay so let's take in some sense
a cross product of all the different of
all the different branches so each two
branch and for each branch we check we
figure out what are files that are in
some sense
impacted changed by this branch and who
does it change so we take views these
two numbers and now we take care in some
sense every we we look at each branch
with each other and then we say what we
really want to see is that actually
different people work on different
branches and so this is a heat map where
on the x axis is file similarity and on
the y axis
a similarity and then you figure out so
you really wanted some sense most people
and branches working in Napa
know in the lower left hand corner so
most pairs of branches are not similar
and they're worked by different people
so if you want to merge something back
together it's just fine if you actually
I have and says there are the same set
of people but they work on different set
of files in different branches that's
fine too right
it's even fine if the same set of people
work on the same set of files in
different branches but what is really
bad is in some sense it's the fourth
quadrant where we see that in some sense
different team members work on the same
files in different branches and then in
some sense it collapses and now you can
actually do something interesting over
time you can see is how did the
organization change and how did the
branch structure change and you see for
example from Windows Vista to Windows 7
there was an organizational change and
that led to the fact that there are
inceptions are more collisions for the
source code control system in Windows 7
than there are in Vista so net every
organizational change is actually the
best when it comes to organizing work
for the individuals so now we want so
now we understand which are the branches
that will be really bad but we want to
do one more thing is actually we want to
figure out which are the branches that
we would best take out of the set of
branches that exists already and so now
the question is how can we do that the
good news is we can go back into the
past we can pretend that we would build
Windows very differently by replaying
the history so what we actually do is we
says ok let's go back into the history
when we started for example Windows
Vista and Windows 7 and rebuild it
differently because we have all the
chickens that have happened over this
period and we take out a certain branch
and we see whether the velocity so how
quick a certain file was in some sense
reached the main branch how quick that
actually changed and we get sometimes to
the following a scenario that you can
really look into the data and you can
model taking out certain branches as we
did here on the left-hand side and we
see that in some sense for certain
branches it really helps with code
velocity because in some sense they are
actually hampering the agility and there
are other branches which are actually
quite good for conflict avoidance and
that you don't want to touch so in some
sense since we know in some sense the
names of all the red dots we can now go
back to the organization and suggest
this is the file this is the branch that
you should really kill and then in some
sense your organization will have more
agile engineering part so with this I
want to conclude I think as what we see
right now is that analytics for software
engineering will have a big impact in
the future whenever I tell the story
within Microsoft people are jumping up
and down and and asking can we have this
can we have this because it just for the
branch analysis alone it leads to a
better development structure higher code
velocity efficient scheduling and most
likely to fewer bugs because the the
merge conflicts will be fewer and that's
where actually many errors are being
introduced so this was one story
analytics there's another story that
goes on and so let me step back a little
bit and look into the hardware area so
in Hardware we typically deal with
circuit designs and people actually
using things like VHDL to describe their
hardware and then generate nest this but
because of various reasons they actually
take the the resulting net list and and
fudge with it so that it in some sense
they change the the generated code but
they won't don't want to change the
semantics of the circuit and so they
actually then use equivalence checkers
they they check that too
circuit descriptions are actually the
same and so why is this a success story
for formal methods because circuits are
just boolean formulas and we have seen a
rapid progress in solving boolean
formulas over the last 15 years and so
far that in some sense this becomes a
standard tool nobody's thinking about it
in hardware companies that they use
equivalents checker that builds on top
of formal methods why did it work
because it's a simple problem these are
just boolean formulas there is no
abstraction in digital circuits as we
have in procedures there is no heap
involved there are no loops involved
there's no recursion involved in some
sense that's a simpler problem then
building an equivalence checker for
software but on the other hand suppose
that we would have an equivalence
checker for software it would be so cool
because we do so many refactorings all
the time and we never know whether we
actually change the semantics so let's
see how we can build an equivalence
checkup for software that really takes
into account the heap the Global's and
and recursion and function calls so how
do we do that
so here's an example a very simple
example obviously how we can encode in
some sense equivalents of programs
so here are two swap functions the first
swap uses a temporary variable and the
second swap operation uses just addition
and negation because we are swapping
integers and we know that they are the
same so how do we encode that they are
the same we generate formulas we
generate the formula from the first
program and so notice that in some sense
whenever there is an assignment to
remember it with this variable gets a
new name so in this sense all the
variables are unique in some sense the
updates are gone and we do the same for
the second one and we name the resulting
value that we assigned to X and y then
swap one X and swap two dot x for
example and then we only say is okay
they are they better be the same so we
could say is oh let's make
sure that's what one dot X is equal to
swap to directs in fact we do something
slightly different we actually add a
negation of what we want to prove okay
so why is this why do we use this
negation because because they use a
particular proving technology that's Sat
solving or actually satisfiability
module theory solving and so if we
actually then ask the theorem prover
does this formula hold with the negation
and it says it does not hold then we
know that the programs are the same the
beauty of an this funny encoding is if
the programs are not the same then the T
improver will give us an assignment of
values to variables and that's exactly
the trace under which these two programs
are not the same so that works pretty
well and so what you see is there are
formal methods in the game but
ultimately we are doing equivalence
checking you haven't seen really a
specification because we use programs as
specifications to so there are lots of
problems as I may as you can imagine how
to encode branches loops heap but let me
just show you one other thing how do we
encode procedure calls so here are two
functions for one and two two and they
both call out to bar and as you know bar
and sometimes get passed that but that
is computed very differently with X plus
y and one with y plus X obviously only
the semantics knows that they are the
same but on a syntactic level they are
very different so and we encode it by
introducing another function that's
called F underlined bar so we could
unfold the method there and suppose now
that we want to check equivalence of
main then we would unfold all the
procedure calls it would result in a
huge formula but we don't have to encode
all these procedure calls because we
interpret now a procedure call as an
uninterpreted function and that has a
very nice effect because for
uninterpreted functions we know that if
the arguments are the same there is
else will be the same so the theorem
prover deals in some sense with a
symbolic representation of the procedure
and not with a real code and so as a
consequence the formulas stay really
small and we can still use our film
toolbar technology so we actually built
a tool and this tool looks almost like
tools that you already use that's a
difference tool right there's different
UNIX for example or window on on Windows
but they work syntactically this one
works semantically and so it builds on
verification technology and the nice
thing is in some sense it's actually
really pluggable for different languages
so what does that mean you can now check
whether two versions that do something
very differently in the way that they
produce a result that they are the same
so this is really the burden and
application compatibility problem so do
these two versions do the same thing and
it also helps with in some sense
automating the the back the conflict
resolution for our branching but you can
also do it over different languages you
can ask the two programs that I have in
il and that I have compiled to x86 the
same it's still an equivalent strength
and so this is actually known as
translation validation so there's one
technique that really addresses both
needs and is very practical and people
never write actually any specifications
because we use programs and
specifications so how does it work so
there is in some sense the summative
tool that takes two inputs and produces
in some sense than a nice result where
the things are the same or not and in
order to adapt it to different source
language there's just a pre compiler
available that takes either C or IL or
arm code or what have you
ok so let me show you a small demo how
that works
so here are two to just seek out a
little evaluation of expression tree and
you see it looks very very different but
if you look carefully enough it actually
should be the same right so one doesn't
use macros it doesn't use a switch
it doesn't use locals it does everything
in Lahaina and the other does the things
a little bit more structured okay so
here's our simdiff tool and if we run
this it will hopefully tell us something
and it says all matched procedures
appear to be partially equivalent so we
are very weight gain what so they should
better be equivalent but you don't check
for example whether the termination is
exactly the same so there might be
problems in termination or there might
be problems and overflow behavior we can
turn on knobs that they can be checked
as well but let me maybe introduce a
slight change here and then see what
happens
suppose that we accidentally use the
wrong operator between the two different
versions and so let's run this again and
see what happens okay so now we get a
counter example a trace let's look at
this trace and in some sense let me
first point out so here we have the
operation so what did we actually change
the operation to I think we changed so
here it is oom the operation is - and
obviously here we see that the e let's
see the first operator is 1734 the
second operator is zero and as a
consequence the result here is 1734
because we else that's right yeah we do
a negation right
17:34 subtracted minus zero is 70
thirty-four but in the other case our
result
let me our result is what's our result
is zero so look like this because in
substance if we actually multiply them
there and they are zero and so then they
are different and so now now that
they're in substance concrete values in
this trace in sometimes we could make
the output probably nicer but we never
executed this code in some sense it was
all tear improving technology that in
some sense gave us counter example and
we repeat reproduce it back into our
into our code in order to figure out
what's the difference between these two
code versions okay so let me continue
there so what we have built and a
current ly building it's lots of tools
that are based that n subsets take some
existing program or existing technology
like test case generation and we make
them semantic based by translating
programs into formulas and that really
helps quite a bit and gives us a new
capabilities so we have seen this for
assume that that really checks for in
some sense correctness of refactorings
for application application
compatibility for compiler translations
and in fact you can even extend it so
that it checks for refinements to so
many of these tools are available
actually on the web for rice for fun so
go to this website and check it out and
with this i want to conclude this part
of the in some sense formal methods
tools and i want to move a little bit on
to future platforms so what's going on
so 20 years ago we had no internet and
today every third person on the planet
is connected to the internet what does
that mean actually for us it means that
for example the browser became a super
important platform because that's how we
typically view everything that's on the
internet and there's something else that
we know is that people spend lots of
time playing can we use those facts in
order to excite them in some sense for
computer science and how do we do that
so we just learned about
Evelyn's checking and one of the fun
thing is we could do something as a game
on the on the web too and so together
with Tao who visit us at some point in
time we came up with an idea to use our
test case generation technology that
uses the improving in the bank to
actually use use it for playing games so
what's the game so there's a hidden
program that's given and you as a
student are supposed to write a new
program and then our technology checks
whether they are the same and then you
win and if they're not the same we'll
give you counter examples and so in this
case it's not a verification technology
that uses very verification condition
generation but it uses a different
technology called dynamic symbolic
execution but in something it might not
matter too much so with this I want to
introduce you to Billy Dee hello who
built the system together with Nicolai
Tillman and he will give us a short live
demo of pecks on the web and so if you
are bold you can actually load it in
your browser and do the same thing can
you hear me now okay cool yeah if you if
you stop listening to us because you're
playing it that's okay so the it's
called PEX for fun comm it's online can
go and play with it and I'm gonna switch
to through the browser it's a it's a
web-based application this is JavaScript
and HTML so it runs on all browsers and
I'm going to tell you a little story
about this website we started we've been
developing text for five years and then
we would go in conferences try to show
it but there was always a problem about
having people have the right environment
to try it so we got frustrated and
decided to write a web-based interface
for that so what you see here is a
basically a text box where you can write
C sharp and then a big black button
where you can run the tool and that's
what we started with in fact we started
with something like this just as a text
box where you can write C sharp and when
you run it it basically tells you
so in this case we we have a method that
takes an input and then there's an
output and it's it's extremely boring in
a sense it tells you that well you
always return what you've entered and
then what we will allow people is to use
the text tool that does that explore
your program and uses dynamic symbolic
execution to generate interesting inputs
so for example if you write more
interesting programs like array axises
that would crash in some in some special
scenario and by the way we I'm gonna
talk about that later but we also worked
on giving a great experience to the user
so in this case in order to hit the
exception branch so in order to go here
you need to do some more advanced
analysis and we used text test
generation tool so in this case so I
change a program and I have a compiler
warning so I'm just gonna change it here
so it's it's it's an IDE like experience
in the browser and that was really the
goal when we build pics for fun now you
can see that you have more interesting
behaviors that are happening in your
program when you pass an empty array or
not enough elements there's all kind of
things that are happening and this is
showing the test generation engine that
Pixies and we deployed that and we saw
that people came in tried the samples
and never come back
they said the breaks you say oh this
great but it's also boring and how she
is suggested to us to turn that into a
game so instead of just having to
explore a problem we are people to
actually change your programs and what
what word form said is basically the
following so we we have two programs so
the user has has to write a program
let's say in this case you always return
zero and then we have a secret program
that is the specification that does
something in this case we're going to
return minus X and now what our tool
does it's gonna check that they're both
the same right
now if they're not the same we report an
error to the user and I guess something
is wrong and this is all in the browser
running in in Redmond and you can see
that now we have we start to have a more
interesting experience where we're
telling the user look you need to go and
figure out the specification and you're
wrong for some cases so when when I is
equals to 1 it's incorrect now the
feedback right now is not good because
you don't really know what the secret
implementation does so we took that and
turn into a real gaming experience in
the website so that's why we're gonna
show you in this other page oops
in fact you're seeing the solution here
ok let's remove that so this is what
players see in impacts for fun they have
their startup method and usually a
pretty cryptic description of the
problem in a sense go and figure it out
because it's a game so we don't want to
give away the solution and they start
asking question to PEX
so they start asking whether their
program matches the secret
implementation and we give them inputs
and outputs so we map X and we tell them
that's for some cases like when X is 1
the secret implementation returns -1 you
return 0 you're wrong you need to fix
that so if you play a game the first
thing you try to do usually is to cheat
by definition so one way of cheating all
those competition game is to actually
build a huge if table and just try to
beat it by brute force now you can't do
that with text because each time you add
a branch we generate a new test case for
it so it's much harder to be than other
game engine and as you can see now we
fixed those two cases but there's still
a new one that's wrong so at some point
you need to kick in the brains and start
thinking and abstractly so we've seen a
lot of solution to this one I don't know
if you have a hint about how to solve
that problem I think the most funny one
that we've seen was X minus 2 X as a
solution and in a sense it's ok not the
best code ever but you know you still
get the warm you won't feel
now you might be wondering you know this
is a bit silly - sex is probably easy so
one of the other challenges that we have
and here you can see that for example
this challenge has been solved 3,500
times and they've been sold quite a
number of times
challenge factorial for example is
another challenge where the student has
to reverse-engineer factorial and we
really don't give him any hint we just
tell him look just go and figure it out
and people who spend hours solving that
we seen deluxe people doing 50 60 70
attempts and minutes before between
every attempt they probably fill entire
tables of numbers on the side and things
like that they really get hooked up and
you can see that when you look at the
live feed so we will this is a trader
like feed of the live activity on the
website and you can see that you have
people playing right now at this
extremely geeky game but in a sense this
is the puzzle this is the ultimate
puzzle if you're into puzzle gaming this
it doesn't get any better and yep and I
guess it's Thursday already so people
are already slacking off at the office
and playing PEX for fun and and with
that I'm finishing the demo yeah thanks
a lot so so we have a picks for fun now
probably a nine month and yeah as you
have seen there are probably a more than
110,000 people in some sense playing
puzzles and there are 500 thousands that
have been solved so far or 450 so let's
see just reflect on it a second so oops
one thing so what we really took is a
programming experience into the cloud
and we sometimes try to understand how
do people learn what are they excited
about and then we came up with coding
dolls and what we also saw it's super
important if people want to do coding
dolls that they actually start
socializing so having the live feed and
in some sense a champion list is really
important and then people ask us oh
actually we can use that maybe for
teaching and automatic grading because
we know in some times when things are
passed and we can also turn it around so
suddenly we are in the we have yeah
450,000 programs in our database and you
can start mining them when people don't
find the right solution what is actually
the reason that they can't solve it is
it is a specification too weak or do
they have problems to express certain
concepts and maybe it would be a great
way to see is whether we can improve our
visual studio Eclipse learning
experience by learning from why people
fail solving certain programming tasks
so there's a lot of research and I would
encourage the audience maybe to each out
to us and and see is whether somebody
wants to work on this area
there's something else also and I think
that the web has really changed the
field but right now we are in another
revolution again and that's actually
that the smartphone's
changed the field again so there are
codes that say is our fiscal what is it
throw to quarter 2010 smartphones so
outsold pcs not sure whether that's true
but it's definitely true for this year
that means there are more smartphones
more computers being sold
then laptops so smartphones the laptops
PCs netbooks and so on and furthermore
you also have to recognize that for many
people a smartphone will probably in
particular in developing countries
the only computing device that they will
have right we can afford to have three
computers they can and and today's
smartphones are as powerful as pcs from
2000 actually many of our smartphones
have already dual-core they're probably
even more powerful than 2000 but they
can't be programmed and so in some sense
that's I think it's really a limiting
factor because people are really
creative and what they want to do and
it's great to have 300,000 apps here and
200,000 there but there are in some
sense billions of people and they need
in some sense something special and
that's really the long tail they want to
personalize the experience on the phone
so if this is a computer and we are some
sense the software engineers why don't
we enable them write programs on the
phone and so with us I want to introduce
touch studio was was developed by
nicolai billion and me how and maybe
before we go into the demo let me add
two things so what we want is actually
address a different audience we want to
see is if most let's say my daughter is
on the phone almost all the time playing
socializing and actually she wouldn't
even write to program and so I think if
we want to generate excitement for the
next generation we should see is what
are they what do they want and where are
they excited so this is in some sense
programming on the phone is not for the
professionals they will have their
laptop on a big screen this is in some
sense for everybody else like me and you
and my daughter so what what's going on
it's actually lots of challenges if you
just think about that you only have a
phone how do you do editing authoring
debugging the good news is a phone is
always connected to the cloud but what
programming model do we actually use in
order to simplify the programming to the
the next one is social aspects people
want to share exactly like in the game
experience they want to share their
programs but as soon as you start
sharing programs
oh you open the box of Pandora because
you have all the security and privacy
issues involved so there's lots of fun
research to do over here and without
further ado let me introduce you to
Nikolaj who will give you a demo of with
touch studio can you give me no okay so
I'm going to show you a brief overview
of touch studio so the basic idea is
that's a programming environment on the
phone you don't need any other computer
because as well as I'm said that might
be the only computer you have if you
have our try to program a mobile device
before you might have noticed that you
normally need a normal PC or laptop
which is really your development
platform and fight a challenge to take
such a small device and turn it into a
relatively productive programming
environment so you can install apps to
do on your own Windows Phones it's on
the marketplace so let let me get
started at the top level there's
basically a project system you can have
different projects let me pick one of
them which is very popular it's an
application that basically allows you to
customize searches to your song library
so by default what it's doing here it's
looking for all of your songs and picks
those which have at least a duration
orbiter have a most iteration of 180
seconds now I can simply run it by
pressing the Run button and it will now
post all of the results to what we call
the execution board it's basically a log
the output of the program and I can I
could pick a song you know and play it
so but maybe I guess yes so that's great
people have said we cannot customize it
let's say you don't just want all the
songs that are short but maybe you want
to look for a particular substring so
now I can go in and edit the code and
what we did here is we created a user
interface that basically allows you to
do everything with the touch of one
finger which is pretty challenging so
navigating through text is extremely
difficult on these small devices so it's
important to have a user interface that
is customized for the finger so I could
say I want all the songs that are short
and I want songs whose name so you're
seeing I'm not in a expression editor we
have quick access to all the properties
that are relevant so I can take the name
of the song and what's available on
strings let's say when I do my search
I'm not interested in lowercase
uppercase so I take the string and turn
it to lowercase and then I can call a
contained function and you see that the
number of tips I'm doing it's it's quite
similar to what you would have to type
in a normal area table so our language
is a typed language not for the sake of
being type safe but in order to provide
intellisense autocomplete with feedback
for the user okay now comes the most
difficult part typing text let's say I
want songs that have the word dick in it
okay
Vick so now I've customized my search
and I can add this modified program
which will now gives me less songs
exactly one I could play it again so you
might know this problem your phone is
playing some sound it's ringing
you're going to a meeting and you want
to turn it off easily right I don't know
if you have seen the Windows Phone it
has like five buttons around it which
button should I pass not to turn it off
so what I can do now is I can customize
the experience how to turn off songs so
I can add a new statement very easy what
I'm going to do is to implement a little
event handler loop explicitly so I'm
going to hide a loop that one forever
and then I'm going to add event and
encode in it which will be executed
periodically and what I want to do here
is I want to check if the phone whether
I turn it over so the phone has a sensor
to measure acceleration and particular
it measures gravitation so if I take for
access the sensors of my phone including
the accelerometer and so I already I
tried out this demo while I was walking
here so on the go I was polling I
figured out I have to look at the Z
coordinate so it has three dimensions in
which it can be oriented or being
accelerated and when that exceeds a
certain threshold and I figured out that
0.7 is a good value then I want to
basically just turn off forever scarlett
playing so I can go to the player and
say stop so let's try that and I should
do a little bit more so this loop you
know run forever and I only really want
to do this check once in a while so I
can add a little sleep statement so this
is a first version of touch studio that
we have shipped just this Saturday and
in the next verse we are planning to
have a better event handling scheme but
this is how it works right now so I can
go into the phone
and say sleep for moments yeah let's say
for one second okay so no on this
program I get my song I can play it we
turn up the volume
okay playing then you go to your meeting
or your boss comes in so to show just
one more thing we could also make it
even more interesting so right now I'm
completely stopping the song so what if
the meeting is over
so I can go in and and refine it a bit
and I can say just pause it and then I'm
going to add another if statement saying
that when I access the acceleration
information of the phone and now I go
below a certain stat salt which is minus
0.7 then I want to go to my player and
go to resume so I don't know if you
could have written this course quicker
in the normal edit or let's try it out
so I pick my song takes a moment to
build up
okay meeting starts meeting us although
good wonderful you think it's almost I
think there's an something so much
excitement in this area we can really
combine the mobile experience with the
cloud for example producing maps and
pathways it's it's really straight line
code but since we are running a little
bit short on time I'll leave you with
this so in some times yeah accessing
maps and locations and there's is a joy
but there are lots of research
challenges open and this is a research
group so we don't know what's the best
way to share in some sense called
security privacy I met edited I
mentioned that earlier power is I think
a really big one right so what's the
best way that we can program those
devices that they use as few power as
possible because we don't want to hear
the song only for a short time and then
battery is gone so I would suggest
download the app it's on the app it's on
the Windows Phone app store and you have
a Windows Phone and let us know what you
think and there are lots of people
twittering about it so it's a it's
really fun it's taking off and actually
my daughter wrote her first program on
the phone as well okay so I talked about
I told you about three stories that I
think are really making an impact in the
next five years I don't know what will
happen in 20 years out but I think we
will see much more analytics for
software engineering in order to make
smarter decisions for engineering I
think we will see many many more tools
that build on very solid logical
foundations except that you don't see
that in some sense there's a Theon clue
behind some of those things and I think
we should
really move on get get over from the
pdp-11
and laptops and move over to the cloud
the data sent to mobile devices and
actually also games let me just make one
comment here
I think the prediction for games it's
it's a 50 billion market in 2015 and
it's all software and there's very
little software engineering right now in
it so I think it's a great opportunity
for this community to have a big impact
with this I want to conclude as you know
I'm only a manager I'm really blessed
with a great team so these are in
something this is my team and there are
lots of websites where you can check out
the stuff that we are doing thanks a lot
yeah yeah I'm happy to take questions
please
Bertrand yeah I now repeat the question
yeah no no I don't think that let's say
in all the industrialized countries I
don't think that will happen in some
sense let's see
so even Apple intentionally doesn't put
the iTunes makes it iTunes available on
on the iPad because otherwise there
won't we no need to buy a laptop anymore
so I think even other companies
recognize that they really want to keep
the laptop life and I want to keep my
laptop but let's go to India in China in
some sense in markets where there is not
as not as wealthy as ours so the
question is what will happen there they
have already the phones today in some
sense a relatively cheap phone but they
are looking for the next kind of phones
and so do we want to give them the
opportunity to in some sense personalize
their experience on the phone if they
don't have a laptop and so that's an
interesting question it's about the
future we don't know how the future will
play out but I think we should consider
that that is a trend that might happen
okay so um yeah the the group is called
research and software engineering
but actually a large part of what we do
is actually programming languages and
ultimately all our ideas are
communicated in some form of language
and that's why I think languages are
important I talked about equivalence
checkers
that's a software engineering tool but
in the end it's also in some sense meets
the notion what's the semantics of the
language so in some sense I think if we
want to deal with programming artifacts
and not only with processes we'll come
to something that can be a widely called
programming language and so that's why I
think it's important that we care about
those things as well coming back for
example to the empirical software
engineering computing community it's
unclear there are lots of claims which
programming language is actually more
productive and there are very few
research results that that can prove
that one is really better than the other
nevertheless we have a strong belief
that one is better than the other so I
think there is in some sense we are
software engineers often bound to our
languages that we are using so it's an
important topic for us
so what I only wanted to say is there
are different companies that have very
different opinions how to set up branch
structure and it's a and we are using
version control system since 20 years
and and there are two different
companies that says this works for us
best and this works for us best and it's
not the same and so why is it that it
works for them better and doesn't work
for Microsoft or the other way around I
think it's a wonderful question to ask
because we change in Microsoft in some
sense branch structure from version to
version to version and typically with a
gut feeling we think this is better
because our organization change or the
architecture has changed but we don't
have in some sense evidence that that is
correct so what I wanted to point out is
man as as a community we seem not to
understand what we are doing and it's
time that we clear this up
yeah yeah okay so little examples the
technology for pecs is based on dynamic
symbolic execution there is a tool
that's not called pecs but sage that
uses dynamic symbolic execution and that
is being used in order to test all file
pauses it has been used to test millions
of lines of code in Windows 7 and and
there's a whole team in Windows 7 and
Windows 7 was for people because of its
success in Windows 8 it has groomed
quite a bit that in some sense uses
exactly the technology in order to find
box access violation box and so the good
news is that technology is so successful
that there were only five facts that we
know of that have been reported to us in
millions lines of code after we shipped
it 18 months ago and that was tested
automatically with sage so it's only
it's not functional correctness it's
only no excess violation no buffer
overruns or whatever but I think it's
working pretty well so I can only show
the little examples here because we
don't have a data center but it should
give you the gist of where things are
going
stop there and take some of the
questions afterwards of course at the
demo fest but for from and his team will
be there and I'd like to thank you both
from her most inspiring wonderful